اا رئيسه الوزراء تونسيه وصلت الى الجزائر
العاصمه ماذا عن برنامج هذه الزياره
القصيره واهدافها
ليه
تاتي تقريبا سنه بعد الزياره الاولى
للسيده بدلا الى الجزائر
الاخيره خاصه في مجال الطاقه
الحدوديه اذا اضافه طبعا اذا السياحه
ويذكرنا وزير السياحه الجزائريه قد زار
تونس
الجزائر
الشؤون الاجتماعيه العمل
هل هناك جاريه تونسيه تعمل في الجزائر
وكذلك تسالينا يقيمون في تونس وكانت هناك
بالمناسبه عده زيارات يعني هذا الوزير
الاول الجزائري ايمن عبد الرحمن زار تونس
والرئيس تونسي قيسي سعيد زار الجزائر
الثالث مرات اخر مره كانت في المشاركه في
القمه العربيه هناك تشاور بين البلدين
بحسن محارمنا في عده قضايا امنيه تتعلق
خاصه بالاوضاع وكذلك في منطقه الساحل
الصحراوي وقد تتوج سيارته
اتفاقيات خاصه الاقتصادي وكذلك في مجال
همم الزراعي والمجال الجمرك شكرا لك فيصل
على كل هذه التفاصيل كنت معنا عبر الهاتف
من الجزائر العاصمه ومن الجزائر العاصمه
انتقل الى همم الى تونس ومراسل كانت نور
الدين باركي نور الدين همم سمعنا لمقاله
همم فيصل من الجزائر العاصمه الى الملفات
عديده سيتم التطرق اليها خلال هذه الزياره
التي تقوم بها رئيسه الحكومه التونسيه الى
الجزائر اليوم
تمام لكن فقط الاشاره انه هنا في تونس لم
تصدر رئاسه الحكومه الى حدود هذه اللحظه
اي بلاغه او
توضيح حول جدول اعمال هذه الزياره وايضا
الملفات التي سيتم تداولها خلال الزياره
التي تدوم يوما واحدا لرئيس الحكومه مجلس
زين فقط الاشاره انه خلال استقبال الرئيس
سعيد لوزير الخارجيه الجزائر يوم السبت
الفارس كان اكد وزير الخارجيه الجزائري
انه مباحثاته مع الرئيس قيس عيد تناولت
خاصه مساله البحث
الممكنه لتنفيذ مخرجات القمه العربيه
وايضا ملفات التعاون الثنائي سواء نتعلق
بالوضع على اقتصادي او الطاقه
الدولي وبالتالي فانه لحدود هذه اللحظه
على الاقل من الجانب التونسي لا نعرف وما
هو جدول اعمال هذه الزياره لكن اكيد انه
لن يخرج عن تطوير العلاقات الثنائيه خاصه
ان هناك العديد من الملفات القائمه بين
تونس والجزائر التي ينتظر توقيعها وايضا
تنفيذ واحد تتحول الى ارض الواقع نعم شكرا
لك نور الدين كنت معنا مباشره من تونس
العاصمه